what's going on everybody and welcome to
a video on some of the current open
source AI image and video editing neural
network applications that you can play
with right now we've come a long way
from just barely generating 25 by 25
pixel images of just human faces to
generating highly detailed images of
anything you can imagine to through
using attention mechanisms and neural
networks being able to identify what's
in the image as well as what's in the
prompt and what in the image does that
pertain to and then furthermore making
edits to those images to now being able
to do even more insane things today
the first thing that I wanted to show is
something I've wanted to do since these
neural networks these diffuser models
and generators have hit the scene and
that's essentially doodle to image so
for example something everyone can
obviously identify due to my exceptional
doodle capabilities is R2D2 of course
not all of you will be imbued with such
artistic prowess such as me but you
should be able to find that this works
quite well anyone can use this right now
for free via hugging face I'll put links
to all the apps that are shown in this
video in the description under the link
to the neural networks from scratch book
which you should also probably check out
another example might be more generic
like a bird or even a Lamborghini keep
in mind that this works mainly by
assuming your doodle is of the edges of
the object or objects that you're
attempting to generate so doing
something like stick figures won't
necessarily work so well you mainly want
to make sure that the exterior shape is
about right and then the network can
essentially fill in gaps so to speak
since it's more meant to generate an
image from edges so you want to also
make sure that if you're using the
doodle that you decrease the size of
that canvas tool tip before you draw
your thing with drawing objects it
doesn't actually just need to be one
thing either for example what is
obviously a Porsche 911 car
and a tree
all this said you can instead also just
edit images rather than needing to
Doodle so if you're just not as good as
I am for example a few months ago I
covered Google's prompt to prompt
research paper which allowed you to make
edits to a prompt and then subsequently
make edits to the generated image from
there the problem here is to at least my
knowledge This research at the time
required you to use AI generation for
the initial image that you are going to
edit and then also cut the stuff that
you need to do to the prompt was very
finicky and much more specific than
where we are now but what this research
did prove was that these networks can
also use attention to identify objects
and regions in an image that pertain to
tokens or words from the prompt in that
image which is what led the way to where
we are right now from here it really
wasn't long until multiple options came
out for editing some pre-existing image
whether it's AI generated or not for
example sample we can use control net
again to take some pre-existing image as
an input then filter it with Edge
detection then Supply a prompt of a
change that we wish to make I think this
works really well for changing things
like colors and styles of an image here
we have an Nvidia CEO signing some 4090
gpus we can actually take this image and
considerably change the styling so for
example we can make it a man with bleach
blonde hair and aviators
not bad if you want a chance at winning
one of those Jensen signed 40 90 gpus
then check out the description for a
link to sign up to GTC the virtual
biannual gtpu technology conference from
Nvidia which in the more recent years
has been heavily heavily dominated by
talks and demos of advances in Ai and a
massive variety of fields I'm expecting
this year to be quite a bit about AI
imagery and GPT models with definitely a
few interesting talks that you won't
want to miss out on plus the awesome
chance to win one of those signed 4090s
making signing up a no-brainer you can
also make sure that you're included in a
chance to win that 490 by signing up
using the link to GTC in the description
of this video often with image editing
you probably will also have an urge more
so to change entire objects in the
imagery rather than say changing
something within some edges and while
you can do this with control net I find
results to vary considerably a much more
reliable option that I've been playing
with and have found is picks to picks
again I'll put a link to this in the
description for the hugging face pics to
picks app that you can play with right
now for free same thing with the doodle
2 image that you can play with that for
free there is a queue that you have to
wait on and if you don't want to wait
for the queue you can duplicate it and
then run it on like a hosted GPU or you
can even run these things locally if you
have a powerful enough GPU so for
example with picks to picks we can
actually swap out my dog here for a bear
but wait there's more where you can do
photos you can do videos and it's video
is just a succession of photos called
frames at the moment it feels like
editing videos in this way is still
fairly Juvenile and not really totally
usable in any real degree other than if
you happen to like the artistic style
that the sort of Fingerprints of this
method leaves but that said this is
probably more like a glimpse into the
very very near future where frame to
frame will be much more consistent and
realistic stick if you're interested in
doing videos longer than five seconds
you can either just duplicate this space
and then run it on one of their hosted
gpus or you can also just download the
app code and then from there you want to
just edit that app.pi to allow yourself
to make longer videos but then also if
you want you can make a lot more
customizations at that point with all of
these AI image and video editing tools
becoming so widely available free and
immensely powerful a demand for research
and results in the in the realm of
protecting personal or otherwise
sensitive photos from being edited by
Bad actors using AI like this is going
to be increasingly needed right now it's
still relatively obvious when photos of
real scenes are generated by AI
especially if you know that know to look
for it but the rate of improvement here
is so rapid that even I often get
accused of things like my backgrounds
and videos being fake or green screened
and people aren't increasingly unsure
and people are increasingly using fake
backgrounds and they are increasingly
believable and a whole lot more of AI
editing is going to continue to improve
at a rapid rapid rate and will
eventually be at a point where it will
be very very difficult to be able to
tell what is real or fake anymore
one interesting example I've seen for
trying to combat Bad actors using your
imagery or videos uh being edited is
photoguard essentially you pass a photo
through photoguard and it applies a sort
of filter to the image and obviously
again images or videos are just
successions of images so you could do
this on an entire video for example
this somewhat does degrade the overall
quality of the image and I do wonder if
there's a less intrusive way to protect
imagery but Beggars can't be choosers
and this is the first and the best that
we have for now I actually don't know if
this is the first but it's it's it's
decent it gets the job done and I think
it's more of like a proof of concept
than anything else it's definitely at
the very least a step in the right
direction and somewhere I think much
more work needs to be done also as noted
by the creators of photoguard one could
obviously easily train a new AI image
generation model to not only just
generate images in general but to also
handle for specifically photo guarded
images because you could just generate
lots of photo guard examples and then go
from there so it would have to be a bit
of an arms race and a cat and mouse game
going forward but this is very similar
to many other security related things
like firewalls and malware detection and
all that stuff like antiviruses but I
can I could really see a future where
there will likely be entire company
things that are formed that their sole
purpose is to protect people's shared
images and videos online using
algorithms like this it will be hard
going forward because eventually there
will probably be things that can beat
those algorithms and then once that
photo is out there and exists people can
probably get around it at some point but
this is definitely going to be a very
open problem going forward and this will
be definitely something that many people
are going to want to be able to use
so it's definitely an important field
you can play around with photoguard on
hugging face today and if this is an
area of research that interests you then
I I definitely suggest that you check it
out you don't even really need the
algorithm that protects the images that
doesn't even have to be a neural network
it could be a far more basic and
lightweight model or even just algorithm
that could instead attempt to maybe
manipulate the mechanisms for how
generative models work but it could also
be a neural network as well or you could
use a neural network to kind of derive
that algorithm
if you're interested in checking out GTC
and potentially winning a Jensen signed
490 GPU make sure to check out the
description for a sign up link to the
GTC it's an all-digital event with tons
of talks and topics in the field of AI
and GPU technology and it's definitely
worth checking out just keep in mind
again that if you do sign up you want to
sign up using my link below uh for a
chance for that 40 90 as well as you
will need to attend at least one session
to be eligible that's all for now I
can't wait to see what comes next in the
AI photo and video editing space and
also just video generation I can't wait
to get to get my hands on some more open
source models for just video generation
so prompt to video the other thing I'm
super curious about seeing hopefully
sometime in this year is much more
robust prompt to 3D kind of scenes and
objects and all that so stay tuned for
those I think I I strongly think we'll
be seeing some cool ones in 2023 so stay
tuned for that and I will see you all in
another video